what is happening reject nation greg
here if you have your notification bells
turned on for this channel
no this is not a re-upload john covered
this trailer for the suicide squad
trailer number two by himself yesterday
and i'm covering this by myself the same
day of except it's probably going up on
friday
morning here's what's happening in real
time it's 11 49
p.m john's supposed to be here in about
10 minutes so we could cover the falcon
in the winter soldier this thursday
night i got back from the airport
about 30 minutes ago and i've been gone
all week
so john's been watching my home and on
top of that too
he's been manning down the ship of the
real rejects leading the charge
looking at the comments people are
responding in a way as if it's the first
time he's ever done solo videos
when it's not i'm saying that only
because the response has been
unanimously
overwhelmingly positive for the videos
he has produced on his own this week for
youtube congratulations to him he's been
doing such an excellent fantastic job
i've seen the videos myself go check
them out the only one i haven't seen
is obviously his reaction for this exact
trailer only because
you know i have to watch a trailer
myself it only makes sense i avoid it
i'm not doing it to be a dick maybe i
should watch it though so i make sure we
don't have the same overlap and [ __ ] or
what i can do is watch his and then go
oh i could say i could say better stuff
for me you guys can just watch both of
ours and then see what we said that is
similar post reaction commentary and
what is different anywho uh he's gonna
be here in nine minutes
let's watch this
it's a live fast die clowns
catcher
in any way and i detonate the explosive
device in the base of my skull
these are your brothers and sisters for
the next few days oh you get a close
look at mongol for the first time
oh [ __ ]
i thought it was the song and the beat
was it
love the weasel looks
polka dot man
detachable
oh
love that peacemaker speech
sorrow you'll be so cool
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die why
[Laughter]
as badass wow
feels so different than the other
trailer i love that the other show was a
lot more
fun you know a lot more punchy and then
the opening
monologue here which i think that is
peter capaldi
uh his character the thinker i love the
dialogue how you guys are trying to act
all dark and
serious you know what how does it feel
to live your life as a punchline and i
feel like that's such a great reflective
commentary for kind of what james gunn
does with a lot of his characters if
that is peter capaldi talking
either way it doesn't matter who like
the fact that they're talking about the
suicide squad
and you see the colorful list of
characters that james gunn has assembled
here for the team you know a lot of them
seem like they can be just silly when
you first
look at them a lot of them don't look
instantly badass not all of them
are bloodsport right you got people like
javelin and polkadot man and weasel
who look kinda goofy when you first see
them what i think this movie will
deliver on
even though one of the taglines for this
movie is don't get too attached i feel
like so maybe some of them will die in
just a funny way maybe some of them will
be so short-lived
i feel like someone maybe like pete
davidson's black guard will be
a short-lived character and they might
just die in a funny way but i feel like
for those who are sticking around for at
least a good amount of the film ones who
might seem a little bit goofy at first
like
polka dot man who i am championing for
so excited about that polkadot man is
something that just sounds goofy
but his powers if captured properly
can be something that is truly badass
and awesome and i just want to take a
side step here i put something
out about this on twitter about david
desmalking who's playing polka dot man
he is one of those character actors and
comic book medium who i think is
severely under recognized he's in the
flash tv show
he's in the dark knight he's in gotham
he's in the suicide squad now he's in
ant-man he's been like a whole bunch of
comic book movies and i feel like
this this could finally be the turning
point for this man's career and he's
earned it dude he's a damn good actor
cinnamon prisoners he's great in that
too the vibe that i'm sort of getting
from that monologue because it seems to
sort of encapsulate so much of this
movie it makes me wonder how much
of the thinker will be the ultimate
player obviously he's going to be
working with the suicide squad
at some point in this movie but
considering what his powers are and that
the thinker being this you know
genius with like telepathic like powers
i'm wondering if there's
if you maybe might be working with
starro to some capacity because i think
the obvious conclusion to draw with the
thinker
being in this movie is you know the
sorrow the parasitic hive mind
they might be using the thinker to be
able to go against the likes of a super
being such as starring as while we're
only getting these moments of starro
like the big scale
visual effects of star not even like
just a full long clean shot like it's
enough to let you know
no that's definitely starro but we
haven't seen any of you know the starro
face huggers and another
side note it's kind of funny behind the
wake of zack snyder's justice league
how starro was i if i'm not if i'm
remembering this correctly starro was
the first
villain that justice league had to fight
against bottom line he was a justice
league villain
that's going on and hashtag restore
that's not reverse which i'm all for
and then for the next dc live action
property to be coming out through hbo
max warner brothers is the suicide squad
whose villain will be star who it's kind
of odd to me just kind of interesting
that's all going back
i'm kind of wondering if maybe the
obvious conclusion about the thinker
because it's the thinker and if there's
one thing i learned from watching the
thinker on the flash tv show you never
really know what's up this guy asleep
so i'm like maybe at first they will use
the thinker well
to deal with sorrow we need that someone
like the thinker
but now i'm kind of wondering maybe the
thinker might be a bigger mastermind or
is working in coordination with starro
as well i just feel like that'd be a
kind of a cool twist but maybe not so
cool if i accurately predicted something
i normally don't accurately predict
things and when i do i
way overly pat myself on the back like
like too much
as if i'm the master theorist when
really i
one out of a hundred i get right what
i'm really feeling is that there's just
so much more to the thinker than we're
even realizing at this moment his whole
monologue seems to shift the whole tone
of this trailer as compared to the first
one because the first trailer
is a lot more fun this one has a lot
more of a serious tone
to it has a lot more of a sense of
intensity and peril
layered throughout from beginning to end
because you know when they're talking
about super villains and
you guys are like a punchline but this
one like blessed act of rebellion i'm
forgetting exactly what the what the
line is that he's saying but
talking about how they can restore their
dignity and then when you're getting to
these images
which look like they're from the finale
dealing with sorrow rising up from the
ground that stuff looks very intense
looks
harsh and how they're asking the thinker
they have the the scene that's in the
first trailer when they're all taking
turns
giving you know ground rules to the
thinker working with them let me just
come on there's something there that
like as much as these trailers are
honing in on uh the new members of the
suicide squad people like bloodsport the
returning characters like harley quinn
and then the fact that starro is finally
gonna be
in live action form i feel like there's
a lot more to think there's a lot more
uh thought you gotta be more thinking to
the thinker let john with the big
vocabulary all right it's not
not my part oh and editing this back how
could i not mention i mean i love jack
courtney
in the first suicide squad movie i'm
excited to see him back here again but
you actually see some real boomerang
action here and as great as
jai courtney was in the portrayal of
boomerang i personally really loved him
i still felt like
boomerang didn't get to do much
boomerang stuff
and here looks like we can get some you
know actual action sequences with him
doing boomerang stuff
so hell yeah and in this trailer too you
gotta see nathan fillion as what a lot
of people have been saying is probably
the detachable kid
that's what tdk would stand for and
looking at the effects there that just
seems like a total blast the fact that
james gunn and nathan fillion
working together again is just super
exciting to me and to watch him be the
detachable kid
it just seems like it's going to be a
blast the effects looked appropriately
goofy
but also cool at the same time i said
this before in the last trailer but i
especially got the vibe here um with
rat catcher 2. i feel like rat catcher 2
in a lot of ways might end up being
somewhat of the heart of this movie or
someone who's more of the hero of the
tale than we realize i think by the end
by the end of the day it's still going
to feel like a full-on ensemble flick
but
i think with her that's where i feel
like a lot of the big surprises will
come from
i think we're all expecting idris elba
to do a great job as bloodsport and he
does look like he's gonna deliver the
goods he looks
incredibly awesome harley quinn margot
robbie who by the way i i feel like is
still
severely underrated like she's
she's not but she also is do you guys
get what i mean we all know
yeah live action harley quinn marigo
robbie yeah she does a great job
she's always great but i don't feel like
we don't praise her enough i know
i know her take on harley quinn's not
for everybody but watching her
transgression
from the first suicide squad movie to
birds of prey to the portrayal that
she's delivering here now and how it
feels like she's able to provide
something a little bit different and a
little bit more mature
each and every time i don't know i just
feel like i feel like we don't give her
enough crap i feel like we don't give
enough credit
to the beautiful work that marco robbie
puts on display here but that being said
i feel like what i've been loving about
the marketing is there's these other
characters here who i feel like will be
the scene stealers
people like polka dot man people like
ratcatcher too i feel like there's been
a lot of hype with john cena because of
the fact that the peacemaker series was
announced before we even got a trailer
for the suicide squad i gotta say like
in both trailers he does look great
like he does he he's he seems really
funny i love the line that you get where
you get
a clearer sense of that i forget exactly
what it was stated as but i think john
cena
said something of how he's like a
douchier captain america
so intense about keeping peace that he
will do as much violence as possible to
keep the peace
like it could sometimes sound
contradictory which
i think john cena can pull off so well i
think what makes john cena such an
appealing personality
is yes upon first appearance like he's
this really big
buff intimidating guy but there's
something about the way he does some of
his dialogue in
films especially where if he's going for
the badass direct line
it kind of comes off a little bit goofy
so i noticed that john cena leaning more
into comedy when it comes to taking on
roles even providing some of that comedy
in movies like bumblebee
but especially doing it here this
character who takes himself
very serious and sometimes the same
stupid [ __ ] is a perfect john cena role
because he can be badass when it comes
to doing the action scenes but the
dialogue he can be really funny in and i
think you're going to get that
perfectly with peacemaker all the shots
of weasel look great i'm kind of
wondering what that line that
the thinker does at the beginning of
like one blessed act of rebellion
i don't know if the thinker is trying to
get them to you know hey even though
amanda waller put the detonator in the
base of your skull maybe if you rebel
you can still get out of this issue i
don't know if this is exactly what
thinker's trying to do or
i don't know if it has something to do
with the fact that we're in this like
latin country um
uh corto
multis i want to say is what it is
there's a rebellion going on there and i
believe
uh alice braga solceria is one of the
leaders of the rebellion
so maybe the suicide squad is
participating in this rebellion come to
find out
they got a starro on their hands they
got to deal with so i don't know if the
you know the thinker's talking about
that in terms of rebellion or meant
something else and like i don't know how
politically commentary heavy this will
get if you follow james gunn on twitter
he can get pretty political they're
dealing with
you know rebellion maybe there's some
stuff that could get political
i don't know if i wanted to get like
politically commentary heavy i feel like
a lot of us probably
wouldn't i'm not someone who is
instantly
offended by something like that i'm not
someone who goes to keep politics i'm
not that kind of guy however
i am hoping that james gunn will go out
of his way to write something more
nuanced for what's going on there with
that civil war happening in
corto maltese as it stands you know the
vibes that i'm especially from watching
both trailers i'm a big fan of the
suicide squad dc animated movies like
assault on arkham uh hell to pay not a
hundred percent but i'm getting a bit of
a vibe
of kind of those movies here well you'll
have the humor
but it won't be a full-on comedy
necessarily it'll still
be able to truly execute more dramatic
more intense sequences will feel a lot
more potent than it was
with the version of suicide squad that
we got a few years ago if i did have a
concern if i did have a concern
like because i don't think the the
trailers are perfect my concern
is the fact of there are so many
freaking characters
and and you know james gunn is
constantly saying like seriously don't
don't get too attached when you are
introducing a gazillion
characters and a lot of them feel like
they're all from their own different
type of genre some of them feel like
they would definitely mesh in the same
world and others feel like they don't
i guess that's the one concern i have is
by the time we see the movie
will it all correlate really well
together we'll all coalesce
or will it feel like jarring i don't
think it will
i i have faith in james gunn i think
that's what where a lot of us are
actually coming from is that we
i feel like james can knock it off the
park i don't love every james gunn movie
so i'm by no means like a james gunn
stan
but i do have faith he'll pull this off
like bringing michael rook in here as
savant
he looks incredible and i love that he
has some of his players that he's worked
with before and he's bringing them into
this movie
king shark you know i talked a lot about
him in the last trailer and then
watching king shark here and then
you know knowing that sylvester stallone
is voicing him
i thought his his scenes in guardians of
the galaxy 2
were a little cheesy but james gunn
strikes me as the kind of
director that once he works with an
actor he gets a better sense of
how to continue working with them how to
direct them and what roles to get them
further down the road
so i think that what he will do with
sylvester stallone
i know he's not doing the mocap he's
just doing the voice i feel like we're
in for something
really special and incredibly quotable i
mean
we haven't really heard full-on lines
yet because he kind of seems like a more
violent version of a groot-like
character but i think it's going to be
something special i think there's a lot
of great things to look forward to here
joel kinnaman surprisingly
i'm very much drawn to in these trailers
as well maybe it's the yellow shirt
i don't know as we're looking at
everything here i'm just more and more
excited for this film
i heard he shot this whole thing with
imax cameras and now the theaters are
reopening in la
i'm gonna try my best to see this on an
imax what do you guys think of this
trailer
leave your thoughts down below i talked
for way too long gotta edit the [ __ ] out
of this one
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button i'll catch you guys
soon
[Music]